you know we spent a lot of the first
hour talking about the issue that really
has commanded the attention of everyone
over the past 18 days
and
there still is another issue that has
commanded the attention of everyone over
the past three months and one day it was
just three months ago yesterday that the
world turned upside down regarding the
coronavirus there's increasing evidence
of some
hot spots that are growing cases
increasing in various parts of the
country the nfl on sunday sent out its
initial protocols to the teams regarding
all the things that must be done in a
facility in a stadium
to keep people including players at
least six feet apart everywhere up to
and including the locker room now it all
changes when they go out onto the
football field that's a different issue
altogether john harbaugh the ravens
coach was on 105 7 the fan in baltimore
on thursday and he provided a fairly
candid assessment of what he thinks of
the league's initial protocols
i've seen all the memos on that to be
quite honest with you it's impossible
what they're asking us to do humanly
impossible
so
you know uh we're gonna do everything we
can do we're gonna we're gonna space
we're gonna have mass but you know this
is a communication sport so we want to
get out there and actually have any idea
about what we're doing on the field
we've got to be able to communicate with
each other in person we have to practice
and i'm pretty sure the huddle is not
going to be six feet space so you know
right
so you know i don't know are guys going
to shower one at a time all day our
guy's going to lift weights one at a
time all day these are things that leak
and the pa needs to get a handle on it
needs to get agreed with some common
sense
um
so we can operate in the 13-hour day and
training camps that they've given us to
get our work done so that's the one
thing you can tell by my voice yeah i'm
a little frustrated with what i'm
hearing there right and i think they
need they need to get that pinned down
now some would say that no one complains
about the rules like john harbaugh but
on this point and and on most points
when he does complain he's got a point
and there is a strange dichotomy with
the extreme measures that are going to
be taken in the facility and that all
goes out the window when it's time to go
play football i think the goal is to
ensure that no one gets onto the field
into the huddle into the fray who may be
positive for the coronavirus but it is
going to create a
major shift in the way football teams do
business and another thing harbaugh said
shireen he's concerned that some teams
won't follow the rules because it is
going to be
something that eats into efficiency and
productivity and if there are some teams
out there that just cheat the rules well
they're going to have an easier time
getting to where they need to be come
sunday
yeah there's a lot of things that go
into this and we've seen it just out in
public right you see people not wearing
the mask because it's too much trouble
and now it's getting hot and they don't
want the mask on and and and everything
that goes with it so we're just seeing
these things out in public so yes i
think it's going to happen on some
football team some guys aren't going to
wear masks and do some other things and
then we're going to start getting those
positive tests and you know i i've asked
around and talked to a few people within
the league who who have have been in on
these talks of designing these rules and
it will be interesting how many times
that guys are tested i don't think it's
going to be every day i think they're
looking at what other leagues are doing
and i think it's probably going to be in
the more two to three
times a week that that players get
tested for the coronavirus so it's very
possible that you could have a guy
test negative for it and then he comes
back and he actually has it the next day
or the day after and it infects
several more players on the teams but i
also wonder if if some owners aren't
going to go out and buy their own test
which could be highly possible robert
craft or jerry jones that says hey i
want my guys tested every day i want to
know when they walk in this building
that they don't have the coronavirus
that they're not spreading it because
there are only certain things you can
can do to prevent it they're going to be
within six feet especially in locker
rooms especially in visiting locker
rooms and out on the field and i know
oakley's designing the face mask the the
shields and they're trying to do some
other things but let's be realistic
about it they're going to be within six
feet of each other and probably will be
within six feet of each other in the
locker room and around that building
see to me sharing i think it's a
no-brainer that every player everyone
who goes into the facility must be
tested on the way in and also test it on
the way out in the event that someone
catches the virus in the facility you
don't want to be setting that person
loose onto the community to spread it to
their family and to whoever their family
members interact with and so on and so
on some of these guys have kids who are
in school right if school is in session
in some of the states where and and look
the trend has moved sharply toward open
everything up and we'll deal with the
consequences later
uh if you've got schools open in the
fall as they they apparently will be and
and you've got kids who maybe catch the
virus at home and take it to school i
mean it's just going to contribute to
the spread so the nfl needs to be part
of the solution not part of the problem
and being part of the solution means
constantly monitoring your guys when
they get there and when they leave and
the testing i've been led to believe all
along the testing will be at the point
where it will be easy and it will be
cheap to do
a screening test for the virus and get a
quick result by the time we get to
september so i don't think two or three
times a week is nearly good enough i
think you've got to clamp it down and
test these guys multiple times per day
or at least multiple times when they
come to the facility on the day off you
don't need to test them but maybe it'd
be a good idea to monitor them even then
because once it gets in
once it's in the building once it's in
the team once it's on the field
there it goes and for all the guys who
are going to be
of that mindset that i'm not worried
about and i've got bigger risks when i
play football and i'm young and i'm
healthy there are plenty of guys who
play football who are morbidly obese
there are plenty of guys that have a bmi
that is off the charts there are plenty
of guys who have diabetes i don't know
how plenty but there may be guys who
have diabetes and don't know it it's a
hell of a way to find out you got
diabetes because you get the corona
virus and covered 19 kills you you've
got older coaches to worry about i i
just i like like so many other things
like we all took it seriously for a
couple of months and then we realized
taking it seriously was inconvenient and
now we're back to like just kind of like
hey well let's see what happens
i i don't know i i just think that there
needs to be if if you're going to have
people in close quarters there needs to
be testing every day sharing every
single day
yeah we've seen these college teams come
back and and test their players and they
have positive tests we had a high school
here in texas that had a player test
positive here in recent days and they
have had started conditioning drills and
they've shut those down now at that
school to try to prevent the spread guys
are going to get the coronavirus at some
point you're going to have guys test
positive can you
keep that number down and i have asked
that question what is an acceptable
number is it five players is it 10
players is it 20 players on a team to
the point where that team can't fill the
team anymore a competitive team anymore
and has to shut it down and and i don't
know what that number is and i'm not
sure they know what that number is but
they they have to be prepared that that
this is going to happen they are going
to get the coronavirus and they need to
take all the precautions that they
possibly can to keep as
few people as they can from getting it
and they need to have full roster
flexibility if in 1987 when the players
went on strike they were able to quickly
fill out at the time 28 rosters with
enough players to play games and not
miss a beat they need to be ready to do
that as well they need to have some sort
of a device some sort of a mechanism and
you know we've had this conversation
before sharing about how the xfl had a
ninth team of players that were kept in
shape ready to go so you could sign
players as needed off of that ninth
roster if you were an xfl team the nfl
may need for every eight teams they may
need a roster a separate roster that is
maintained for that purpose so guys come
in ready to go you're not trying to get
a guy up to speed who's been sitting on
his couch for the last three weeks when
the phone call came on friday that they
need him on the field on
sunday hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports